THE FORMER PRESIDENT, ONCE
AGAIN INVOKING THE BIG LIE
DURING A SPEECH IN ARIZONA OVER
THE WEEKEND, WHERE TO THE
SURPRISE OF NOBODY, HE CAME OUT
FORCEFULLY BEHIND THE SHAM
AUDIT, AND MILLIONS OF VOTES
CAST IN, AND AROUND PHOENIX,
DURING THE LAST ELECTION.
BUT, SCIENCE WAS ALSO UNDER
ATTACK DURING THE EVENT, EVEN
THOUGH HE DID MANAGE TO MAKE A
SOMEWHAT GUARDED ENDORSEMENT OF
THE COVID VACCINE WHICH IS,
CERTAINLY, HELPFUL TO SOME
DEGREE.
CNN'S KYUNG LAH, WITH THE
STORY.
>> WRAPPING AROUND THE 5000
SEAT THEATER AND PHOENIX
ARIZONA, A LONG LINE OF DONALD
TRUMP FAITHFULS.
>> NO MASK, TAKE OFF THE MASK!
>> JUST 36% OF THE PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTY ARE VACCINATED.
CASE OR, IT'S MORE THAN DOUBLED
IN THE PAST 2 WEEKS.
FUELED BY THE MORE CONTAGIOUS
DELTA VARIANT.
STEP INSIDE WITH US AT THIS
INDOOR RALLY.
WE FIND DATA, AND THE REASON IS
ABSENT.
BUT, EVERY SEAT IS FULL.
NO SOCIAL DISTANCING, OR MASKS.
-TO-ONE AS THIS CROWD CHANTS,
AND SINGS FOR HOURS.
THIS RALLY IS STILL SUPPORTED
ALLY THAT TRUMP WON ARIZONA,
AND THE 2020 ELECTION.
BUT, IT IS ALSO ABOUT THIS.
>> NO ONE SHOULD BE FORCED TO
TAKE A VACCINE AGAINST THEIR
WILL.
>> FAR-RIGHT POLITICS, KING
HERE.
SCIENCE, THE VILLAIN.
>> IT CAME FROM A LABORATORY,
AND DOCTOR FAUCI SHOULD BE IN
PRISON FOR WHAT HE DID OVER THE
LAST YEAR.
>> 2022 ARIZONA REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES, FEEDING OFF OF
IGNORANCE.
>> MOTHERS DO NOT LET THE MASK
OUR CHILDREN AGAIN.
>> THEY ARE ALL HERE FOR THE
HEADLINER.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
WELCOME THE 45TH PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
DONALD J TRUMP.
>> HOW ABOUT THE VACCINE?
I CAME UP WITH THE VACCINE.
I RECOMMEND YOU TAKE, IT BUT
ALSO BELIEVE IN THEIR FREEDOMS
100%.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
BEHAVIOR?
>> EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
AND MAYBE IT'S NOT POLITICALLY
CORRECT TO SAY, BUT IT'S
STUPID.
DANGEROUS, AND STUPID.
>> THIS IS AN EMERGENCY ROOM
PHYSICIAN AND PHOENIX, AND HEAD
AND SPIN ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE COVID BATTLES BEGAN.
>> WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE WILL
BE THE IMPACT OF THIS?
>> OF THE RALLY?
OH, THERE WILL DEFINITELY BE AN
INCREASE IN CASES.
NO WAY WITH THE DELTA VARIANT,
PEOPLE AREN'T GETTING THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THIS BEHAVIOR, REGARDLESS OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING, IS A
CESSPOOL FOR CREATING VARIANCE.
>> HOW FRUSTRATING IS THIS TYPE
OF THING FOR YOU?
>> IF YOU MAKE IT A DECISION
ABOUT YOUR OWN HEALTH, YOU CAN
SAY, WELL, IT'S YOUR LIFE.
BUT WITH INFECTIOUS DISEASE,
IT'S THIS CONTAGIOUS, AND
AFFECTS THIS MANY PEOPLE, YOU
ARE JUST AFFECTING YOURSELF,
YOU ARE AFFECTING EVERYONE
AROUND YOU.
>> YOUNG LAW, JOINING US FROM
SCOFFED STILL.
WITH CONSERVATIVE VOICES URGING
VACCINATIONS, DID YOU SEE ANY
RESPONSE TO THAT THIS WEEKEND?
>> NOT IN THIS CROWD.
IT IS SO BAKED IN, IT IS SO
PART OF THE DNA OF THE
POLITICAL CONVERSATION NOW,
REALLY, NO, THAT IS THE ANSWER.
WHEN YOU TALK TO THEM, THE
PEOPLE IN THIS PARTICULAR CROWD,
REALLY, VIEW NOT HAVING A MASK,
NOT HAVING A VACCINE, AS
SOMEHOW MAKING YOU MORE
PATRIOTIC.
THAT IS THE DANGER HERE, SAYS
THE DOCTOR.
WE WERE ALSO SHOWING HIM THIS
VIDEO, WHERE HE SAID THAT
BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH A STRONG
MINDSET, AND MANY OF THE PEOPLE
THERE WHO ARE NOT WEARING MASKS,
HE SAYS, SOME ARE ELDERLY.
SOME ARE OVERWEIGHT.
HE IS HOPING THAT THEY ARE
VACCINATED, BUT HAS SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT, THAT ANDERSON.
>> KYUNG LAH, APPRECIATE IT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, DOING
ITS OWN POLLING OF THE
UNVACCINATED SINCE THE SPRING,
TO TRY TO FIND OUT WHY THEY ARE
HESITANT.
THE REPUBLICAN POLLS WITH DEEP
ROOTS IN THE PARTY, WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION IN AN
UNOFFICIAL CAPACITY.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT, THE DOUBLE
MOUNT FOUNDATION, HELPING
COORDINATE, AND FUND THE FOCUS
GROUPS.
JOINING US NOW.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO WHAT
YOU ARE DOING, AND I WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU WHAT WORKS TO
REACH THOSE, OF ANY POLITICAL
PERSUASION, WHO, FOR WHATEVER
REASON, ARE HESITANT.
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
OF GETTING PEOPLE VACCINATED?
>> PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES, SIMPLY, THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THE INFORMATION THEY
ARE BEING PROVIDED.
THAT THEY HAVE STARTED TO DENY
THE DATA, FORGET THE FACTS AND
SIMPLY REFUSE TO BE AN
EDUCATED.
THE SKEPTICISM IS UNACCEPTABLE.
PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
NERVOUS ABOUT A VACCINE THAT,
STILL, IS NOT FULLY APPROVED BY
THE FDA.
BUT THAT SAID, WE KNOW THAT
OVER 90% IN THE HOSPITALS ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNVACCINATED.
WE KNOW THAT THIS VACCINE IS
SAFE.
WE KNOW IT WORKS.
THE GOVERNMENT WOULD EVEN SHUT
IT DOWN FOR 6 INSTANCES, 6, OUT
OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE,
A FEW MONTHS AGO, WHO MAY HAVE
DEVELOPED A BLOOD CLOT FROM IT.
SO, THIS IS A VERY CAREFUL,
VERY WELL RESEARCHED, VERY WELL
STUDIED VACCINE.
I WILL GIVE YOU FOR SOLUTIONS.
NUMBER ONE, 4 GRANDPARENTS WHO
ARE WATCHING, IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO CALL YOUR GRANDKIDS.
THE CLOSEST FAMILY RELATIONSHIP
OF ALL IS GRANDPARENT,
GRANDCHILD.
THEY BOTH HAVE THE SAME ENEMY.
GRANDPARENTS, CALL YOUR
GRANDKIDS, TELL HIM TO GET
VACCINATED.
2ND, TEACHERS.
WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE A BACK TO
SCHOOL EFFORT.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO CALL PARENTS
THEMSELVES, CALL YOUR CLASS,
AND SAY, WHAT WOULD BE GREAT IS
IF YOUR STUDENTS ARE VACCINATED,
AND I THINK YOU SHOULD GET ONE
TOO.
3RD, NOT JUST YOUR OWN DOCTOR,
BUT PHARMACISTS, NEED TO GET
INVOLVED.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO TRUST THEIR PHARMACIST WHEN
THEY ARE SEEKING MEDICAL
INFORMATION.
AND 4TH, IT IS DONALD TRUMP.
WE WANT TO SPECIFICALLY INVITE
TRUMP TO THE WATCHES AND SAY,
COME ON HOME, YOU AND I WILL
ASK PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED.
WHAT WE LEARNED, AND FROM ALL
OF THE RESEARCH, AND IN THIS
WEBSITE, WE KNOW THAT IF BIDEN,
AND TRUMP, MAKE THE REQUEST
THAT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LISTEN
TO IT.
SO, LET'S TRY TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
LET'S PUSH TRUMP TO JOIN JOE
BIDEN, AND THE 2 OF, THEM
TOGETHER.
IT'S THE VACCINE, LET'S GET IT
OUT, AND LET'S DO IT.
>> I UNDERSTAND, EVERYONE HAS
FREEDOMS TO DO WHAT THEY WANT,
WITH REGARDS TO THEIR BODIES.
HOW EFFECTIVE A MESSAGE DO YOU
THINK IT HAS BEEN FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT THIS WEEKEND
SAYING, LOOK, I GOT THE VACCINE,
I AM PLEASED WITH HOW I DID IT,
I RECOMMEND YOU GET IT, BUT I
ALSO UNDERSTAND, YOUR FREEDOMS.
IS THAT ENOUGH?
>> NO, IT IS NOT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE.
ALSO, THERE HAS TO BE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
EARLIER, TOM FRIEDMAN, DOCTOR
FRIEDMAN, AND THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY ON THE STUFF.
ANDERSON, I WANT TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING WHICH YOU PROBABLY
DON'T WANT TO HEAR, BUT I WOULD
RATHER SEE TOM FRIEDMAN ON THE
SHOW THAN ANTHONY FAUCI.
FAUCI HAS BECOME SO POLITICIZED,
SO POLARIZED, THAT EVERY TIME
HE SPEAKS, HE TURNS OFF PEOPLE.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE, MORE
EXPERTS, LIKE TOM FRIEDMAN, WHO
ARE ACTIVE, AND KNOW THE DATA,
AND KNOW HOW TO COMMUNICATE IT.
IT IS PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY,
NOT SINCE OUR NATURAL
DISCUSSION.
MOST IMPORTANT FACT OF ALL, IF
90% OF DOCTORS HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED, DON'T THEY KNOW
SOMETHING YOU MAY NOT?
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY ARE
TRUSTING THEIR COUSIN, RATHER
THAN THEIR DOCTOR.
>> IT'S INTERESTING WHAT YOU
SAY ABOUT DOCTOR FAUCI.
BECAUSE HE VIEWED YOU'RE SAYING
THROUGH A POLITICAL LENS,
THROUGH A LARGE SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION WHO WAS VACCINE
HESITANT, OR REFUSED TO TAKE IT,
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN LABEL THAT,
THEN THEY DISCOUNT ANYTHING HE
HAS TO SAY.
OR, IN FACT, DO THE OPPOSITE.
>> EXACTLY.
AND THIS IS A SERIOUS SHOW.
BY THE WAY, IT IS ONE 40 AM
HERE IN LONDON, AND I GOT UP,
AND STATE, UP TO MAKE SURE I
COULD DO THIS.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT IT, AND
MEANS WE NEED TO PUT THE BEST
SPOKESPEOPLE OUT THERE, AND IT
ALSO MEANS THAT WE CAN DEMONIZE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
WIN OVER.
THAT YOU DON'T HATE PEOPLE,
BECAUSE THEY MAKE THE WRONG
DECISIONS.
YOU LOVE THEM, AND TRY TO
EDUCATE THEM, AND TRY TO MOVE
THEM.
LISTEN, I GET FRUSTRATED, I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN THE LAST
FOCUS GROUP I DID.
BUT, WE NEED TO DO THIS.
DEMONIZING THESE PEOPLE, ASKING
THEM TO FOLLOW A PROPER COURSE.
>> ONE QUICK QUESTION, LAST
WEEK, IN A REPORT BY
CORRESPONDENT ELIE REID, IN
ALABAMA, SHE TALKED TO A MOM --
SORRY, IT WAS ARKANSAS.
HER 8-YEAR-OLD CHILD GOT COVID,
ACCORDING TO, MOM WAS QUITE
SICK, HAD A VERY HIGH FEVER, 4
WEEKS, AND WEEKS, AND SAID IT
WAS STILL NOT FEELING WELL, AND
WANTED TO TAKE THE CHILD TO A
DOCTOR TO SEE WHAT DAMAGE WAS
DONE.
IF ANYTHING MORE CAN BE DONE TO
HELP.
THEY ASKED, WELL, WILL YOU NOW
GIVE ACCIDENT TO PROTECT OTHER
KIDS AND SHE SAID, NO.
AND THE ANSWER WAS, SHE DIDN'T
TRUST THE GOVERNMENT.
HOW DO YOU REACH HER?
WITHOUT CONDEMNING, WITHOUT
CALLING NAMES, JUST ALL OF THE
MANNERS, HER PROTECTING THOSE
KIDS.
>> WE HAVE SO DESTROYED OUR
DEMOCRACY.
WE HAVE DONE SO MUCH DAMAGE TO
THIS COUNTRY, THAT IS WHY WE'VE
BEEN RIDING OUT THESE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
WHEN SCIENCE IS SO POLARIZED,
AND SO POLITICAL, YOU CANNOT
TELL PEOPLE THE TRUTH, THAT
THEY WON'T LISTEN TO YOU, YOU
KNOW THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE.
I'M AFRAID IT'S PERMANENT.
SO, I WISH I COULD GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER, AND I TOLD YOU THE 4
WAYS WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
ANDERSON, WE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
NOT FOR WEEKS, OR MONTHS, BUT
YEARS.
IT'S NOT NAME-CALLING, IT'S